LEONARD AUSTIN: My
name's Leonard Austin.
And I'm the CTO of Ravelin.
Ravelin is a fraud
detection company.
We specialize in detecting
credit card fraud.
When a customer tries
to buy something
from one of our
merchants, the merchant
will then stream us
all of that data.
And we will use a load
of machine learning
behind the scenes to try and
analyze transaction and make
predictions around whether
that user is a genuine user
or a fraudulent user.
We consume a huge quantity
of data through our API.
It's not just our
clients' real-time data,
but it's also all of the
historic data as well.
It's everything
from transactions
to customers' orders, along
with all of their transaction
history, and potentially
location data as well.
That's typically terabytes
of data per client.
Security is really
important for us
because our clients are trusting
us with all of their data.
So we go to
extraordinary lengths
to ensure that the data
that we hold is encrypted
and securer than
closed-source projects.
Cloud security, for us,
is better than on-prem.
There's a lot of
aspects of on-prem
that we just can't
really facilitate.
And Google can.
So on-prem has the
problem of having
to manage your own security.
If we had a warehouse of
racks and data centers,
we'd have to protect ourselves.
With the cloud, we
don't have to do that.
So all of that is
outsourced to Google.
Above and beyond that,
the actual cloud itself
and the way that
Google structures
the file system
means that one file
isn't stored on one computer.
It's stored across
multiple disks, which
means even if someone
was able to get access
to a particular disk,
a physical access,
they wouldn't actually be able
to get any data from that.
We migrated from another
cloud provider to GCP.
And the decision to move to
GCP wasn't taken lightly.
And we did a lot of
evaluation of GCP
before deciding
to make the move.
One of the major
factors that made us
think that it was the
right thing to do,
we could work with
our account manager
and easily get access
to the documentation
to prove to our auditors
that GCP was secure
and it was up to scratch.
The other thing that
we are able to do
is work closely
with the KMS team.
And working with those
guys, you could really
see that there was a focus
and a roadmap that really took
security to the next level.
There's a number of
services that GCP offer
that we couldn't get elsewhere.
An example is like the
Identity-Aware Proxy, which
you can't get anywhere else, and
encryption at rest by default,
but also the further step that
enables us to supply encryption
keys to Google, so that Google
can't even unencrypt the data
if they wanted to.
The Identity-Aware
Proxy, for us,
is a really nice service,
because it basically
enables us to protect all
of our internal dashboards
without having the
complicated setup of a VPN
and having to get our users
to install VPN clients,
install credentials,
have two-factor.
It's all baked into the
Identity-Aware Proxy.
And because we're used
as a Google app engine,
it just means that there's
no additional set-up
for anyone within the company.
So those are all
really strong factors
that suggest that Google
really cares about security.
And it enables us to trust
Google with all of our data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]